the terrorist threat in afghanistan is
growing the u.s military believes there
are what they describe as 2 000 hardcore
islamic state fighters on the ground
isis k or islamic state coruscant is
thought to be mainly based in kuna and
nangarhar provinces but has the ability
to operate nationwide an enemy of the
taliban as well as the west isis
fighters carried out last thursday's
suicide bombing at kabul airport that
killed dozens of afghans and 13 u.s
service personnel
the other key threat is from al qaeda
unlike isis al qaeda has close ties to
the taliban the u.s led invasion
disrupted its training camps and killed
many fighters including eventually its
leader osama bin laden but al-qaeda
numbers are rising inside afghanistan
again with a u.n report putting them at
about 500 with many top militants
believed to be hiding out in the border
region with pakistan
a former special forces officer says the
west's defeat in afghanistan means
there's a greater chance of foreign
fighters signing up
those that are um are motivated to join
the calls typically like to join a cause
that is winning
and so the probability of this being a
recruiting sergeant as the phrase goes
for terrorism
is very high
so what to do about it the uk and its
allies have developed a sophisticated
network to combat terrorism in
afghanistan they can use spies and spy
planes and cyber hacks to monitor
activities on the ground
when a threat spotted they could take it
out with an airstrike remotely but
there's a chance of civilian casualties
as reportedly happened on sunday when
the u.s launched an airstrike in kabul
and that could then turn more
communities against the west
special forces also have a key role
though of course it would be very high
risk even more so than before for them
to operate on the ground in afghanistan
right now
the west will be hoping these
capabilities can contain the threat but
the complete withdrawal of troops on the
ground means it's going to be a lot more
challenging with or without the
taliban's help